hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today I'm finally doing
another Q&A for hitting a hundred and
sixty-five thousand subscribers thank
you guys so so so much this is going to
be my IGN Q&A because people had so many
questions about me walking an IGN about
me leaving IGN that I should talk about
but I also kind of wanted to wait for a
little while off to having left to show
you guys what my content would be now
that I'm allowed to do Let's Plays and
streams so I kind of wanted to like let
people know this is what you're going to
get from this channel instead of leaving
IGN and just talking about IGN all the
time but to that note I really want to
sell this out by saying just thank you
so much to everyone who subscribed when
they found out that I was leaving who
really wanted to follow my content to
all the people who left really positive
feedback on the EA video even on the
ninh DS video I feel like I don't know I
feel like people have been as excited
about me getting to create content on
here again as I am and never in a
million years that I expect that so that
has been really really awesome and I
really appreciate the support I'm
smoking about this before but I had I
think 80,000 subscribers before I even
walked at IGN and this channel slowed
down so much when I started working
there because I wasn't allowed to talk
about games and it's cool that I feel
like you know announcing that I was
leaving and then making the content that
I have recently it kind of picked back
up again and I feel like I've gotten the
ground back that I kind of lost so you
just saw this very positive right now so
thank you but to that know it so people
don't get confused no I am NOT doing
YouTube or streaming full-time people
keep asking I am starting a new job I'm
still in the process of waiting for a
visa but I think I'll be a now to
announce it within the next 10 days
we're just waiting on government
approval before everything can go ahead
but you know for reference because I've
seen some people be like it seems like
like she didn't have plans when she left
IGN it took IGN six months to get me my
visa a full six months this has taken a
month so it could have been a lot worse
it's just an extremely complicated
process but anyway to the questions I'm
answering the most common questions that
I got first one is an exciting one okay
now you don't work at IGN you want to
tell us the truth about game reviews
being paid off it's not a thing just
know no point was there ever any
monetary influence at no point was I
ever asked to change a review school at
no point was I ever us to increase our
view score just not the thing that
happens in the time that I've worked in
the industry which is seven years now I
haven't heard about it happening at any
outlet and I think that if it did happen
other journalists would leak it so so so
fast like I would have refused to work
at IGN if that were a thing if that were
a real thing and I knew that going into
the company I would have refused to work
there but say it had happened I would
have leaked it I would have told the
whole world that that was happening and
I think every other games journalist or
most of them would do the same thing
because it's a story that we all kind of
loft that or an idea that we all kind of
laugh at the thing people bring up the
most often is Call of Duty white is
called you to get a 10 out 10 every year
coach it doesn't get a 10 out of 10
every year I actually don't think IGN
has ever given color Judy a 10 out of 10
that conception I think comes from IGN
giving Cola Judy a high school and I've
never reviewed a Call of Duty game so I
can't really speak to this but my guess
is that the public looks at it as though
all the call of duty games are the same
so why are they getting these scores but
the review is don't look at previous
games when they're reviewing something
and maybe you could consider that a
floor in the review system but I I think
I agree with the policy that you are
reviewing the game that you were playing
right at that moment you are reviewing
that individual game and your review
should be just as valuable to someone
who has never played one of those games
before as it would be to anyone else
you're not reviewing it as it exists in
a franchise and I think that's that's
where that comes from
second question related to that how can
i GN call themselves journalists when I
ads all over the site for the same games
being reviewed and this is an
interesting one that I do really want to
talk about the general answer is that
the writers don't see the ads and I
understand the idea that it's like wool
you can't say that you have this huge ad
deal with a certain company like with
Blizzard and if they aren't gonna get
mad if you talk [ __ ] about a game and
that's true but the sales team is the
one who would have to deal with that it
would never come through the writers
basically I can't even name most of the
sales people who work at IG and I
wouldn't know their faces if I passed
them in the street but I would say they
know who
all of the content creators are and if a
writer writes something that pisses off
publisher then maybe that publisher
would get mad with whoever the sales
person was that made a deal with them
but that will never come to the right of
the writers would never have any idea
that that's happening I don't even know
if that ever has happened like that's
how well removed that it is I think
there are totally reasons to criticize
games media but sites being paid off is
in my experience not one of those things
did you have a writer of you and then
change your mind on the score later yeah
and that's not strongly but that's a
thing that's you know almost impossible
to avoid I gave super hot like a 7.5 I
think and I did that because looking at
it as a picture I decided it didn't it
didn't evolve enough using new weapons
sure but it doesn't it doesn't evolve
the mechanic at all it just has that one
thing that you just do repeatedly in
different environments so I kind of felt
like that wasn't enough to it at the
time but that's me trying to look at it
with this like excessively critical eye
that often moving on from it I feel like
I remember it a lot more fun Lee than
that what were the best or worst
projects you worked on at IGN my literal
favorite things to do at IGN well I Gian
first the IGN fuzzfeed docksiders is
still going up and that was all me
and of course incredibly talented video
editors and fellow producer Andres who
worked really really hard on that edgy
at firsts where basically you would go
to a studio for a couple of days I did I
think four of these in my time there
interview bunch of developers put
together sort of documentary style
packages on a specific topic and I just
I loved doing that I also really like
writing previews which was a component
of IGN first sometimes it was really
hard like when we did the one on Detroit
become human which is content that I was
really happy with you know we went to
Paris two days there I think we did like
12 interviews in two days which is a lot
for the record and then I transcribed
them and that is not a normal thing to
do usually you would use a transcription
service but it was like something about
the way the date the time walked out and
I transcribed them and
you do what's called a paper edit web
based on my transcriptions and based on
what I had decided the topics of each
video would be I was sort of like
cutting quotes and giving time codes for
each of the quotes and like creating a
story that you've been assemble and then
it goes into the video at it and becomes
the interview piece that stuff where I'm
not on camera but it's stuff where you
know I'm planning content for a full
month working on edits working on
basically like how to tell the best
story with the content that we were able
to get in the studio visit and of course
you get to visit awesome studios so it's
great and then I also get to write a
preview most of the time which is like
several thousand words about an
unreleased game and and I love doing
this I also really loved expert mode
which is a Facebook exclusive show at
IGN that's similar in concept where the
process was talked to a one specific
developer pick a game pick levels in the
game and then questions that you want to
ask surrounding those levels and
basically like play through the game
with that dev and really try and talk to
them about the ideas that they had going
into that game I did one for rocket
League and then one for Psychonauts with
Tim Schafer and I loved working on both
of those for sure my favorite projects
at IGN he was project that I worked on
IGN was the IGN show that was a show
that we were doing there was kind of a
gaming show aimed at teens and that was
all fine I had done TV stuff before and
none of that was new to me but the
reason I hated it I guess I can I can
paint one really specific picture I was
at this uncharted The Lost Legacy event
and I was the only female journalist in
the room at that event which is not
uncommon but it's just a thing that when
it happens you notice it not in any
negative way not in a way that's
uncomfortable you just when you're
different to everyone else in a place
you feel that and so I sit down at my
station and I'm also planning to write a
preview and you know I'm getting ready
to play the game and I'm getting ready
to take notes and all that stuff and
because we're filming a segment for the
IGN show just it just got to a point
where they told me to put down my
notepad and they were like fixing my
makeup and had a camera on my face and
weren't filming the game maybe well like
had a camera on my hands playing a
controller and there's a goal they're
fixing my hair and like using hairspray
on me while I'm playing this video game
that was just so disheartening to me
especially as the only woman in the room
it was this this thing that I had worked
my whole career to be against like I
never wanted to be pretty girl looking
pretty playing video games Tiki on
camera and it like didn't matter that I
cared about the game and it didn't
matter that I was like trying to take
notes and like you know cover it
effectively it was just look nice while
playing video game and that's the
footage that they used again in a room
full of exclusively male peers it was
just an awful feeling and I understand
you know the need for b-roll and why
they need that kind of footage but it
just felt just so against everything I
had ever tried to do I had a thing where
I wouldn't read anything unless I had
had a hand in writing it and the IGN
show that just wasn't an option it was
always reading a script that someone had
written that was often full of errors it
was like they clearly didn't know as
much about videogames as I did so I
would often have to like corrective
on-the-fly yeah I just I never wanted
that for myself I never wanted to be go
who sits and gets hair and makeup done
for an hour to read something else
someone wrote off a teleprompter but
everyone wants super hard on it and I
didn't have a problem with the product
when it came out it was just that
feeling just got punched me so bad that
was only a three month period I do want
to say but it was it was three months of
working almost every weekend and working
the late nights and early mornings and
not getting to do the actual job that I
was supposed to be doing so it was a bad
three months what's your best memory
from walking there this is like hard for
me to answer because there are a lot of
really good ones but they're almost
entirely centered around just so many of
the cool experiences that I got to have
with friends like this year's e3 was
tons of fun getting to go to Germany
with all my friends and work stupidly
long days at Gamescom and just like
being on the podcast and and and talking
to these people that I loved about stuff
that I loved for a living was just
constantly feels as awesome as you would
imagine that it would but also you know
there's some really cool stuff that I
got to do like I was the first press in
the world to play the actual build of
Detroit become human to play like
certain chunks of that game I was the
first person in the world to finish
for horde mode along with Sean Finegan
and a bunch of the devs or rather I mean
outside of the dev team we did have
Deb's helping us it was the first person
in the world to play dockside it's three
and I love dockside is just a lot of
really cool stuff that if I had told
myself even ten years ago or even like
when I had been playing dockside is one
that I just you know I just wouldn't I
just wouldn't believe so I wrote this
question down because I got it
apparently 23 times which is why did you
leave look I spoke about that on my
leaving IGN video but people just like
really don't want to take it for an
answer
so to everyone who is listened to we say
this before I'll say it again and left
IGN because I got a job offer that I
think is better for my career that's it
there are other reasons like money and
stress but it is ultimately just
something that I decided was a good
career move for me that that came when I
I feel like I stopped learning as much
working in IG and I didn't feel like I
was going anywhere and I had some people
be like oh but you just started hosting
to fix like that's a huge accomplishment
but I need to point out that's not my
career goal my career goals would never
to be a host my career goals were never
to be someone that you saw on camera all
the time I actually fought very hard
against that at IGN because I wanted to
be like I'm a writer I've trained in
writing I started out as a write I was
highlighted ID and as a writer so I'm
far more interested in growing as a
writer producer and I didn't feel like I
was able to do that anymore at IGN and I
just wanted to be able to be more
creative and and again just do things
that I think will be you know step
forward for me and not just a step no
not even a step it's just like it IG and
I felt like I wasn't stepping anymore
that is that is the reason I promise
there is not some other grand reason and
then I got a couple more questions that
are just kind of like people just just
looking for gossip that's like why do
someone you're really great people leave
IGN what's going on there and I got that
one a few times and I just want to say
with stuff like this questions like that
or questions about whatever drama that
you're interested in just remember that
the people that you're asking these
questions to a people if you're like so
hungry to find out about drama that you
stop thinking with like human compassion
who just it would ask you to just
think if you can be doing something
better with your time and I hope that
you you think about that I hope that
that occurs to you that it's like I get
that you want some juicy story that you
want me to be sexually harassed for some
reason which is very weird but just
remember I'm a person too and you're
saying that about me you're saying it
about other people or saying any of this
kind of stuff is really hurtful to the
people involved you don't have any
reason to listen to me of course but I
just want people to have that thing in
their brain where they think about it
but you at least think am i making up
[ __ ] about a video game journalist and
and desperately wanting something to be
wrong in their lives and like
desperately looking for a story because
I'm so entertained or am I thinking
these are real people who go through
real [ __ ] not trying to tell you doing
anything wrong I just hope that you
think about it alrighty everyone I'm
Alanna I'm so excited to hopefully be
able to tell you guys where I'm going by
the end of this week pending the US
government saying that I'm allowed to
stay in this country and let me know if
you have any more questions those are
all the biggest ones that I thought
already you guys I'm Alana and I will
see you next time